uh you're watching the press preview
it's a first look at what is on
tomorrow's front pages time to see
what's making the headlines tonight with
daily mirror economist susie boniface
and the spectators deputy editor freddie
gray they'll be with us from now until
just before midnight so let's check out
some of those front pages and on the
second day of the invasion in ukraine
the financial times declares russian
forces descend on kiev picturing
ukrainian soldiers lying on the stomachs
with guns drawn in the capital the
telegraph reports on the battle for kiev
the eye has a nearly identical photo and
headline similarly here's the times
battle to save kiev the mail calls kiev
the city of courage the guardian
describes the city as being on the brink
referencing the ukrainian flag the sun
calls the conflict zone the thin blue
and yellow line while the mirror shares
ukrainian president zielenski's message
of hope we are not afraid he said today
and a reminder that by scanning the qr
code that you can see on screen join the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you
watch and listen to what our reviewers
have to say and i'm joined now by susie
boniface and uh freddie gray thank you
for your patience as we just listened
into uh developments in new york there
uh let's start susie pabst with you
what's interesting is that pretty much
all the front pages have a very similar
headline but most of them are carrying
this photograph of ukrainian troops on
their bellies on this motorway bridge
crucial bridge
into kiev doing their best to protect
their
city yeah and so here we are on day two
of the russian invasion and it's not
quite going according to plan
um so on day two if you were
the the superpower that russia thinks it
is and thinks it should still be you
should really have landed a city by now
you should have taken over a major
centre of population and they haven't
managed that they're still on the
outskirts of kiev hopefully they're
going to be there for a bit longer yet
now they are expected that they they
have enough force on the russian side to
roll in at some point but uh uk
intelligence was saying yesterday that
the day one objectives had not been met
uh the ukrainian authorities and there's
no
verification for this as saying that
they've killed or wounded about 3 000
russian troops while losing a few
hundred of their own
we do know that about 18 000 submachine
guns have been handed out to ukrainian
citizens to use and any passing russian
soldiers that they might see
and we also know that 200 missiles have
rained down on ukraine from russia and
that's
actually although you know any one
missile in your back garden is one too
many but 200 is not a lot there were
more than 500 on the first opening night
of if you remembers that the george
bush's shock and awe first war on the on
baghdad back in 2003.
so 200 missiles is not anywhere near as
many as putin could unleash if he wanted
to
and so we're not quite sure really
although you know kiev is plainly
digging in and they are um out for a
fight and they are going to give putin
far more um trouble than he was
expecting perhaps and maybe that's what
slowed things down a bit and given him
some pause for thought but he's
definitely not unleashed what he could
unleash yeah freddie let's look at the
front of the guardian uh one of the few
papers actually that hasn't gone with
that picture of the troops instead it's
got a picture got a picture of
a young boy looking out of a train um
crowds of people trying to get onto
trains today at kiev railway station to
get out to be evacuated from this city
and of course we're all fearing a huge
civilian uh death toll and what struck
me today looking at a lot of the footage
was just how like footage from world war
ii it was people desperately clamoring
to get onto trains or cowering in
basements
it really is uh i don't often like to
commend the guardian but i think
actually their picture is a much better
picture choice
uh because it speaks to this refugee
this human crisis we're facing
um and while i'm i'm all in favor of
people sort of rallying behind
the ukrainians and i think susie makes
some good points
uh
you know i think that the sadness is the
overwhelming uh air power
and potential
increased troop enforcements that russia
can send in at this stage
um is terrifying
uh and while we all want to want the
ukrainians to show a good fight and all
that i think we need to be realistic
about the fact that they are being
uh overwhelmed i think it will be a
fight and i think it's actually awful
that it's going to be a fight in some
ways because that will mean the death of
more young men on both sides uh freddie
susie i know you're going to stay with
us all evening uh just uh uh don't go
away just want to read you uh something
that president zielinski has uh issued
on a video in the last few moments it's
quite a long statement but this is the
gist of it he says this night will be
harder than the day special attention is
paid to kiev you can't lose the capital
he told his people tonight he said this
night the enemy will use all its forces
to break our resistance
vile cruel and inhuman tonight
they will storm the president speaking
to the people of ukraine